In this video, we'll explore some considerations for preparing your assets in your DCC Tool
of Choice.
Before exporting, you're going to save yourself a lot of headaches on the Unreal Engine side
if in your DCC Tool, by the way, DCC stands for Digital Content Creation, you set up
things with clear names and materials.
We recommend looking at Michael Aller's UE5 Style Guide, which is a perfect example for
a wide range of naming conventions that are actually quite well accepted throughout the
industry now.
Be sure your scene is well organized and combine and attach meshes ahead of time when you can,
which will simplify how they get imported into Unreal.
Pay attention to any objects that have been scaled, especially in a non-uniform way.
Look for tools that reset the scales, x-forms, etc. whenever you can.
Keep the scenes as close as possible to the world origin of 000 as when they get too
far away it can start to create floating point errors.
And then whenever it makes sense, set up your pivot points ahead of time so when they come
into Unreal Engine, they're not far away.
Basically a similar comment to what we're saying about the origin of the world, but
on a per-object basis instead of for the entire scene.
A reminder that Unreal Engine uses the Z-axis for up and the unit type is centimeters, and
whenever possible you should try to set this up in your DCC tool before exporting, although
Unreal Engine is getting better and better at identifying the up direction as well as
the unit type from a variety of sources and converting them on the fly.
Still, this remains a best practice, especially if you don't want to deal with scaling issues.
If we take a brief look at the Forklift Scale Map found in Content Maps Forklift Scale,
we can see an example of our little Forklift brought into Unreal, and we might not know
right away that it's little without context.
Standing next to it is a third-person character at its normal scale, and we can see of course
this feels a lot more like a child's toy now.
The problem here was that this was imported with inches instead of centimeters, whereas
the correct imported Forklift is over here, and as we can see next to our character, it
is at the correct scale because it was imported with centimeters set up correctly.
You'll find that when you first bring in an FBX file into Unreal, you'll be presented
with a wide range of options for how you would like that FBX data ingested, including things
like whether or not you would like to generate collisions, combine meshes, whether or not
you want to convert to Nanite, what you want to do with normals, if you'd like to change
the units, if you'd like to generate light maps, if you'd like to set up LOD groups,
if you'd like to convert the materials, and the list goes on and on.
And so again, before this all comes to Unreal, in your DCC tools such as 3ds Max, it's good
to set up things like a standard naming convention.
Here is the current state of the Michael Aller style guide.
It says UE4, but it works exactly the same for UE5.
You'll see some basic principles in here, and then some very direct approaches for how
things get named, for example a prefix of SK for skeletal mesh, M underscore for material,
T underscore for texture, and so on and so forth.
Here we see the example of ensuring that you don't just have a bunch of objects named box
rectangle shape, and instead they're named things like bench, handle, floater, etc.
As we see that those translate over into the Unreal Engine Outliner.
Keep in mind that if you have an object with multiple materials, that object will translate
into Unreal Engine with those same material slots listed as different elements.
These material IDs will determine which faces get which textures and materials, and the
more material IDs that a mesh has, the more expensive it'll be to render as every single
one of those materials will create an additional draw call, also known as a rendering pass.
Then the raft map, which we can find under maps raft, we have a simple example of different
material IDs set up as they came into Unreal via an FBX import, and we have gray, brown,
black, red, silver, and then we have a hey raft that seems to have come in at the wrong
scale, and then over here one where all those materials have been combined to reduce draw
calls and add additional optimization.
This could be done in a DCC tool, though it could also be done directly in Unreal Engine
via something like actor merge actors simplify.
And then we have this other version of the raft, which actually has combined all those
materials together, reducing from five draw calls to one.
Pivot points determine where an object will get placed in a level, as well as how it will
scale and rotate relative to that pivot point. Typically you want a pivot point to be located
at the ground level of an asset so that it will easily place on the floor of your project
and somewhere near the center. By default, if the pivot point is centered to the object
but the object is offset from the center of the world, that pivot point will be relocated
to Unreal Engine's origin, zero, zero, zero, but you can prevent that from happening by
activating the bake pivot in vertex option when you import through the FBX dialog box.
Let's take a look at our pivot points by opening up the pivot map in our content maps
folder. And from here we'll see two forklifts, one with the name pivot bad, and one with the
name pivot good, hopefully for obvious reasons. We can see that pivot bad has its pivot all
the way over here and is a little bit awkward to move, and once you start to rotate it,
things get very confusing very quick. Over here on the other hand, much easier to move,
and rotation makes a lot more sense. So how do we fix the bad pivot forklift to make it
closer to the good one? Well, if we go into our modeling tools here, which also have the
shortcut of shift F5, we can go down here to X form, edit pivot, and we have a number
of different options here where we can center, put it up top, put it to the right, put it
over in the world origin, or put it in the bottom. We can adjust all this manually of
course as well. If we think that we want it to be near the front of the vehicle, for example,
or if we're thinking about how the vehicle might begin to rotate, whether it's a front
wheel drive or rear wheel drive, that might actually start to influence what we do as
well. Now that I'm looking at the forklift, I realized I was looking at it backwards,
front wheel drive, rear wheel drive, and once I accept that, so for example, if it has rear
wheel drive, we could have something like that happening. And this doesn't affect just
this one instance of the model. If I go and I find the pivot bad model here, we've actually
adjusted it at its base mesh level. As we can see, this new one we've just dragged in
also has the pivot in that location. So this is different from the option of right clicking
and going to our pivot and doing a pivot offset, right? That is something that is temporary,
and we'll go away once we click on the object again. Also note that when you import into
Unreal Engine, you can import an entire scene instead of just an individual object. Nowadays,
we're seeing this done even more and more, not just with FBX, but also GLTF, GLB, and
USD files as well. What's quite nice about this is you can actually get a preview of the hierarchy
before you import it. You can import components and preserve the hierarchy and pivot points of
individual actors. You can import components into a single blueprint actor class. You also have
separate tabs for static meshes and skeletal meshes if they're part of the same scene,
and you have a robust materials menu to adjust how those all come into your project.
If we take a brief look at our forklift hierarchy scene, we can see that an entire blueprint has
been generated that contains the entire hierarchy of the FBX scene as it came into Unreal. So if I
open up that blueprint file, I will see all the geometry in here set up very similarly to how
it was created in its original DCC tool, clearly with some attention paid to things like pivot
points and even how the tire would rotate. If you like, we could test this very briefly in a level
sequence by bringing in our forklift, adding in a transform track, changing where it moves from
here to about frame 150, setting this to be a linear speed and seeing if we can get the tires to
rotate appropriately. Double clicking on a blueprint will actually bring you right to the child
component. Here though I have the wheel selected, I probably actually want to have the rear right
and the rear left control points selected. I could set their rotation, move forward a little bit,
and then bring their rotation perhaps to something like 180 degrees.
And we can see those tires in the back are moving. Now note I can't actually do this with the other
wheels directly because they do not actually have these same control points. And if I click on the
wheels directly, the pivots are not in the center of the wheels, they're over here. So I could continue
to work with this and modify it here in Unreal, or I could change it back in my DCC tool. But here's
just a very quick example of what I was able to do just by bringing this over into Sequencer and
working with the existing hierarchy. In the next video, we'll explore Triangle Count.